اه مارتن عضو في مجلس إدارة أنصار توتنهام
هوتسبير
يثقون في أنه ينضم إلينا من
بيدفوردشير
آه في إنجلترا سيدي أم
توتنهام أحد الفرق التي تقول
إنها ستنضم إلى هذا
الدوري الممتاز ويبدو أنهم
غير مهتمين نوعًا ما بـ  إبداء الإعجاب
بك وبني بعد
ذلك ، بعد ذلك ، هناك مجموعة كاملة من المعجبين الخارقين الجدد
الذين أصبحوا نجوم رياضات خارقين ، الأمر كله
يتعلق بالمال ، أليس كذلك
تمامًا ، وأشعر
بألمك تمامًا ،
إننا نشعر بالإحباط الشديد نشعر بالخيانة
لأن  يمكن وضع خطة مثل هذه
دون أي تشاور على الإطلاق مع
المؤيدين ،
ربما لأنهم كانوا يعرفون أن هذا
سيكون رد الفعل الذي عرفوا أننا سنكون
ميتين ضده وهذا له شكل
وإحساس صفقة تم إبرامها في
ممرات مظلمة أو خلف أبواب مغلقة مع
لا تحترم على الإطلاق أكبر
المساهمين في اللعبة ،
أهم الأشخاص في كرة القدم
، وهم
المشجعون ، يقول جاري لينيكر إن كرة القدم لا شيء
بدون جمهورها ، لقد رأينا ذلك بوضوح.
على مدار الاثني عشر شهرًا الماضية ، إذا وقف المشجعون
كواحد ضد ما يصفه
بأنه مخطط الهرم المضاد لكرة القدم ،
فيمكن إيقافه
في مساراته ، هل تعتقد أنني أعني
بالضبط أين تعتقد أن هذا موجود
لأن هناك من يقول
اسمع  هذا مجرد ضغط ضد
الاتحاد الأوروبي لكرة القدم في هذه المرحلة ، نعم كل شيء يتعلق
بالمال الكبير
أه ولكن هل سيحدث ذلك حقًا ،
هل هو حقيقي
في هذه المرحلة ، كيف تشعر
جيدًا أننا نشعر أنه معًا يمكن لعشاق كرة القدم
منع جماهير كرة القدم هذه من الاتحاد و
سوف نتحدث إلى مجموعات مؤيدة أخرى
وأه
هذا وقت أن يجتمع المنافسون
ويقاتلون معًا
لأنهم
كما قال جاري نيفيل بالأمس ،
لقد رأينا هؤلاء الملاك
كأوصياء ولكننا الآن نراهم
محتالون ، هل تعلمون أن كرة القدم في حالة
حرب أهلية اليوم ، دعونا لا نخطئ
في ذلك
وأه ونحن بحاجة للقتال
معًا وآمل أن يكون الدوري الإنجليزي الممتاز هو الدوري الإنجليزي لكرة القدم
الذي سيفعله السياسيون الحكوميون.
مارسوا الضغط كما
قالوا بالأمس بنفس القوة
التي أشاروا إليها لأننا بحاجة إلى
مواصلة
القتال وأنا أعلم أن مشجعي كرة القدم سيكونون
مجرد يوم مظلم حقًا إنه
الشيء الوحيد الذي يواجهه مشجعو كرة القدم
هو تسديدة مغلقة.  المنافسة
التي تعرفها تقريبًا مجموعة مغلقة من
نخب كرة القدم الأوروبية ، وبعضهم
ليسوا حتى في دوري الأبطال
توتنهام آرسنال الشامل ليسوا
حتى على
طاولة قمة أوروبا هذا الموسم لماذا
يجب أن يكون لأي ناد حق إلهي في
البقاء
على هذا المستوى مع عدم وجود الجدارة الرياضية
ولا الهبوط ولا الترقية ولا الآمال
والأحلام
تطمح الأندية الأصغر